because in nineteen pandemic has
affected people's health finances and
daily lives they are increasingly
turning to governments health care
organizations and other businesses for
information using online and phone
support this sudden unprecedented
customer demand is overwhelming customer
support resources in this video we will
walk you through a rapid-response
virtual agent solution which is built
using template that we've open-sourced
this is to help you address immediate
customer queries and relieve pressure
from your contact centers let's take a
look here's a web-based example let's
say a user is looking to know more about
covert 19 and how it spreads they can
just click on the suggestion bubbles
like what is covered 19 or how does it
spread and it responds accordingly based
on whu-oh and CDC recommendations if the
user wants to get a screening done they
can just click on the start screening
button and enter straight into screening
the flow here will depend on the users
selection but let's say none of those
apply they select no and are presented
with some more symptoms let's say they
are experiencing signs of low blood
pressure and indicate yes in this
response the screening indicates that
they should seek medical help
immediately let's take an example of a
user whose situation is not this serious
they start the screening process don't
have any serious life-threatening
symptoms but are experiencing some cough
and minor shortness in breath the
screening now gets deeper into their
travel history where they have been in
the last 14 days and then verifies their
age to suggest a course of action or
other resources like how to manage kovat
at home if you would like to customize
the solution with your own web UI to
match with your brand you can absolutely
do that here's an example let's say a
user is interested in knowing the number
of cases in the United States they can
select the auto suggestion and get a
response they can also type their
question say they're concerned about
receiving packages
is it safe to receive packages the
responses are coming from the same agent
it just has a custom UI now if you have
users who may want to call in through
the phone to ask some questions and to
get screening done you can easily assign
a phone number we have one assigned here
let's call you can ask me questions
related to coab is 19 and I will provide
some answers based on publicly available
information disclaimer I do not provide
medical advice diagnosis or treatment if
you are experiencing a life-threatening
emergency call 911 IO what is the
difference between flu and corona virus
a coded 19 infection has the same signs
and symptoms as the common cold and you
can only differentiate them through
laboratory testing to determine the
virus type is the virus or borne studies
to date suggest that the virus that
causes coded 19 is mainly transmitted
through contact with respiratory
droplets rather than through the air as
you saw the open source template is pre
trained with common code 19 related
answers and shi'ite screener you can
enhance and update the experience as
often as needed through dialogue flow
please refer to the documentation for a
quick guide to get started
you